okay here we are for the second day in a
row second day in a row streaming live
on Twitch and a lot to talk about a lot
to discuss
there is this CNN Town Hall thing going
on let's listen to it a little bit what
do we do well this is what we did with
the tobacco companies we sued them we
took them to court because you know what
happens people who profit off of harmful
behaviors when you take away that money
because you take them to court and you
sue them as I have done it's
extraordinary how they will change
behaviors yeah I don't know if this
should be the focus of today's stream
because first of all not that it's all
townhalls the candidates just go
consecutively for hour after hour after
hour and I just don't know if you know
it's like I have other stuff to do we
could potentially take phone calls
there's there's a bunch of different
things going on I just don't know that
this town-hall stuff is what we want to
spend the entire stream doing I mean are
people finding this interesting I don't
know this is part of my plan what we
would do is one reinforce the EPA under
this administration right under under
President Trump who by the way you know
I'm gonna steal a line from Governor
Inslee governor Inslee I'm stealing your
line and he said yeah so I don't know I
mean I don't think we need a whole
stream of this as people are suggesting
yeah thanks Herbert for subscribing with
twitch Prime I appreciate that also
thanks to origins and tall tales who is
now subscribed for two months in a row
at tier 1 and also shod zero six zero
who subscribed with prime and legalize
ranch who subscribed for their first
month with twitch prime so a lot of
things to do today oh you know what I
realized I left up the zero of 50 to 5
of 15 from yesterday let's make it a
more modest goal today of 12 yesterday
we did not
really get anywhere close to 15 so let's
make the goal a little more modest if we
get to 12 website members today I will
open up the phone lines for you I have a
few different things that we can do one
is yesterday I meant to I use an app
called pocket to basically carry around
articles that I want to read on my phone
it makes them accessible even when I
don't have internet access I said
yesterday I was gonna go through some of
the articles that I have bookmarked
which people said they would be
interested in and I didn't get a chance
to do that so that's one thing that we
can do I've been sent this interview
that was published a couple of days ago
the Candice Owens show on Prager you
with a guy I've never heard of named
George farmer and we can look at a
little bit of that although again I
don't know that I can tolerate that much
of it I'm also glad to check out my
multi reddit four stories that may be
interesting stories for tomorrow's show
and I don't know yesterday I started I
got through like the first world of
super mario world maybe as a goof at the
end of the stream I'd consider playing
that but I'd rather take phone calls and
hear from people although we've made you
know again yesterday we didn't make it
to our goal of 15 new members today
we're setting it at 12 and hopefully we
can make it if you sign up on my website
I will thank you
extensively all of that stuff right that
all of those normal things apply and the
number will be six one seven eight three
zero 47 50 it's not open now it will go
to voicemail I see that there are a
bunch of people already trying to call
in let's just take a look at what sorts
of voicemails are coming in I don't know
if I'm calling other streamers today
maybe I will will will see I see that
being suggested yeah you know I see a
couple people like xored Berg saying me
playing Super Mario was awesome I lost
like 20% of my viewers when I did that
so I don't know that that was actually
really that great
okay let's just take a listen to a
voicemail that came in we are not
opening the phones yet but these are the
types of things that are coming in just
constantly when I mention it
hey David hey I wanted to if there was
one thing that I could give to the world
that wish the world knew is that what
you leave behind you leave behind for
yourself I was thinking about it it's
like the Sequoia forest over there
though where all the routes are
connected and very existential and
another example of a voicemail let's
take a listen
hello longtime fan so I was wondering
why do you think that I was wondering if
you think that right
okay well that one didn't go super well
and then one last example of voicemails
coming in fast and furious but the phone
lines are not yet open let's take a
listen
hi David from Toledo foreigner Neriah I
was the new knows how defamation lawsuit
knows don't know a thing about it but
certainly something I could look into or
maybe people will tell me what it is
that that person is talking about okay
so that's that and maybe we'll get two
phone calls today let me say thanks to
Brent Brent five Brent Brent and ten
three I don't know there's threes and
fives which I guess sub in four letters
subscribing with twits prime I Ofili I
appreciate it
hard revenge subscribing for the second
month in a row at Tier one and glad to
have you here on Twitch this doesn't
look like you're crying though very much
true alluring lord L subscribing for the
second month in a row with twitch prime
are you following UK politics at the
moment David very interesting the past
couple of days yes my lead story on the
broadcast show today was about British
politics and
origins and tall tales cheering 100 bits
I appreciate that
thank you very much people asking what
is my chess rating I actually have li
chess here as well which is also a
possibility I'm not that good I think
I'm rated like 1100 or 1200 something
like that potentially would take a
challenge or two maybe from cheers or
something like that because otherwise I
get too many challenges all right let's
jump into some of this Candace Owens
thing I'm gonna do playback speed 1.25
just to make it slightly more tolerable
and see what's going on oh the steady
wool okay okay guys we are rolling in to
another episode of the Candace Owen show
and this one is a wedding special no I'm
not talking about William and Kate or
Harry and Megan I'm talking about media
I am getting married this weekend so we
decided that we were going to make this
a wedding special and introduce you guys
to my fiance future husband George
farmer welcome to the Candace Owen show
is this this camp that's a joke right I
mean is this considered comedy on the
right I bet we talked about how nervous
I was do this episode so weird
you wait this is this is who she's
married this is really her husband or
something listen I freaked out for about
like two months saying we couldn't do
the episode because I just didn't know
how to talk to you about you're gonna
freeze every time we spoke yeah I know I
was freaking out about it but then I
figured it would be easy because I could
just post something on Instagram and
answer ask for what they wanted to ask
us and he would just go through it
number one question that we were asked
about our relationship which was how did
you guys meet and it is a very very
interesting story I mean you know the
story from my side okay so you came to
do an event in London in December and
that was to launch turning-point UK with
Charlie but a second she's married she
just met this guy ten months ago or nine
months ago and the first time we
actually met was at the RSC Club rule
automobile club in London on Palomar and
you'll give him speech and I think from
that moment onwards the connection was
made and then the next night we had this
highly convoluted dinner which we've
talked about we talked about before
we're basically useless
else was hosting it and I thought I was
hosting it and then eventually who
turned up three hours late I would like
to make that point out I showed up three
hours late to a dinner where I was
supposed to be seated next to him
because I had no idea the dinner was
going on yeah I don't I I don't tell in
my personal life people know I do not
tolerate that three hours late I mean
what's wrong with people until about two
hours into the dinner correct and it
wasn't just me there it's a preference
it was like a whole host of people who
are waiting to have dinner with you wait
and then after that we went back and
forth to America where I came to America
to come to a student action summit at
the end of last year and then came back
to the UK and then by mid January we
were engaged right so just to get a
second so they were engaged within a
month of meeting what did this is this
entire thing satirical context we got
engaged after two and a half weeks maybe
oh I think it was about that right right
which is pretty crazy yeah well when
romance I believe I know it was really
strange cuz it was so not my character
for me to ever think that I would be a
person that said I got engaged after two
and a half weeks or to lose pledged the
question and something that Allie
Stuckey and I talked about because
that's the question incorrect usage of
it by the way this has got to be a joke
I agree with you he's not pregnant about
to give birth or probably already has
given birth by by the time this episode
airs but and she actually met her fiance
really quickly and they got married and
one of the things that we always talk
about is we kind of live in this culture
now where people think that you need
there's this like system right you need
to meet somebody you date that person
for a length of time three years five
years then you need to get engaged and
so it goes and yeah the people that I
know in my life or the relationships
have last the longest always a very
quick engagement my grandparents were a
very very fast engagement I know another
couple that's 25 years they dated okay
let's talk about anything other than
live in New York and Los Angeles who
tend to be like how dare you do this
without really any comprehension of
what's actually going on in the real
what I like the most is that they they
also pretend that the animals are super
innocent like I get the animals saw you
all I wants to do is be your friend and
they're so out of touch with reality and
way people are living overseas I mean
I've only been to Africa once I went
Uganda and there's you know the wildlife
there's there's certain hours of the day
where I stayed we were not allowed to
walk outside because the animals are
vicious hippopotamuses I mean there
recall of all of these animals is like
Lion King right like what everybody was
so nice on Lion King and now we have
people going this this is unwatchable I
mean who's paying for this
stuff ivory I send me this stuff and I
say okay let's do a stream let's analyze
it there is just nothing to analyze I
mean this is just the most vapid yeah
what are they even tacking about the
talking about this this is just it's
laughable I don't even understand what
this is who would watch this stuff and
what I mean is this you know the I'm on
the Friday show this week I got an
audience question why is it that the
right has The Grifters and the left
doesn't have grifters the only way you
could have a grifter like this is if the
audience glorifies people on the basis
of sort of like a cult of personality
because there's there's nothing here
this is completely empty of all
substance and meaning and value I just I
just I really don't get it
somebody says try skipping ahead another
15 minutes alright let's try going 247
and seeing what's there we're gonna get
this absolutely right and you can go
pretty much anywhere and just had the
most incredible but I never order
hamburger when I'm overseas and you guys
get the breakfast wrong too like
American breakfast you are absent ISM is
baked beans in America you know it's a
weird time you don't you like weird
textures so I'm surprised that you're
into the bean thing that means a great
great this is I mean are these people
considered intellectual leaders anywhere
like is there is there actually a
movement that these people are running
in some way I mean it is the III just
can't do this guys I'm sorry I can't I
can't do this let me just thank people
instead Apache COI subscribed with
twitch prime I appreciate it poopy man
of course subscribing with twitch prime
and mash nerf subscribing with twitch
prime I appreciate I appreciate that
yeah we can't this we can't watch this
anymore
oh this video keeps getting recommended
to me socialism doesn't work maybe we'll
just check out a few moments of it my
opinion on the English breakfast yeah
I'm not into beans for breakfast I don't
eat pork which includes like the blood
sausage and the bacon and stuff so it's
it's not really for me
mr. president ladies who said this I'm a
socialist and a very different kind of
socialist from your rich friend can't
prevent clock was 1930
and the speaker was a rising German
politician called Adolf Hitler in 1930
the contention that fascism had emerged
out of socialism was accepted across the
board it was an observed historical fact
fascists marched under red banners on
meeting their leaders believed in high
tariffs in workers control all factories
in a moment in common production of and
distribution and yeah and exchanges we
just had gone and there was a reason I
don't think that this is for us although
this is interesting and I'd be
interested in checking it out later okay
yeah that that's that's a lot for us to
to deal with let me say thanks to shavon
shavon shavon Kavanaugh Siobhan Kavanagh
is this evening's first web site a new
member of the day we were at one of 12
we really failed yesterday miserably we
had a goal of 15 new website members to
open phones and take phone calls and we
got five so today I decided we're gonna
drop the goal to 12 and we have won 1
out of 12 so far and we will see if we
get the phone lines open today it would
be extremely extremely depressing if we
didn't for a second evening in a row
would I interview Ben Feingold the chess
player I do watch his videos Howard
Stern mentioned to me yesterday
interestingly enough I would be
interested in interviewing Ben I guess
didn't sargon of akkad make a video
about you David I know he's made videos
about me but I don't I don't know I
don't watch his stuff Baker Baker full
asks how much is it to be a member with
the coupon code half 19 it's only 3
bucks a month or $30 for the year do I
play chess yes I do
I am David Pakman on Lee chess and you
can see right here maybe I would take
challenges from the audience maybe
people who cheer with bits or maybe
if people if people want to play against
me in chess sign up on my website and
then let me know what name you signed up
with and then I will take a challenge
from you here live on the stream how
long have I been drumming I guess about
15 years Hasan plays chess all right I
would potentially play his son Oh Sargon
fans Berggren brigaded your YouTube
video on Andy No who cares I didn't
didn't notice and I mean they can do
whatever they want doesn't doesn't do
much for me one way or the other
Nick Swenson has just signed up on my
website thanks Nick nick is new member
number two of 12 for the evening
can i play cannot improve on Lee chess I
don't know who that is so I don't I'm
not really sure about that
but oh people are saying people watch
Sargon to see if he has a point says
legalize ranch okay
well that's certainly your prerogative
to use your time however you see fit
okay let's take a look at some of the
articles I have saved on Pocket I've got
a bunch of stuff here every year I
always get an email from pockets saying
I'm in the top 1% talk about elitism 1%
of readers on Pocket let's see what I've
got on here I'm 20 I have thirty two
half-siblings this is my family portrait
seemed like an interesting article the
hero who betrayed his country see I
don't even remember bookmarking that but
it seems interesting inside the conflict
at Walmart that's threatening it's high
stakes race with Amazon business stuff I
read a lot Hospital introduced a robot
to help nurses how Baer canisters fail I
don't know why I bookmarked how bear
canisters fail I don't I don't camp
there's no point in Holly went around if
you're gonna make these mistakes
mmm-hmm so what are the mistakes over
flow if you can't fit all your food and
you put some stuff outside of it that
makes sense you need everything in the
in the canister leaving it unlocked
seems like an obvious mistake leaving it
open seems like an obvious mistake
leaving it rolled away
or just it rolls away to bear Kanaka the
canisters were rolled into the creek
overnight yep that seems problematic
structural failure hmm all right okay
well those are the things I guess to be
careful of when it comes to bear
canisters I guess I'll market is red
because I think I'm done with it
the rise and fall of French cuisine how
to have a good flight nutrition science
has broken the egg study shows why I
assume it's related to eggs being good
that good that good 5 lies you've been
told about generational wealth this is
just stuff I read sort of like in my
free time the future of the city is
childless safe deposit boxes aren't safe
I've been thinking about getting one
that's why I must have bookmarked that
everyone's miserable and here's what we
can do about it the secret life of a con
man I think I bookmarked that after
reading Frank a beanie owls catch me if
you can
why job seekers get ghosted seems
interesting how air conditioning created
the modern city I've been reading a lot
about air conditioning confessions of a
phony telephone psychic seems
interesting secrets about restaurants I
learned by working at Nobu that seems
interesting let's check that out let's
see what's going on here Oh Brandon
presser all right
night after night no booze apana miss
Myrna no no Robin Williams snacked on
yellowtail sashimi Nobu is now huge we
know that this person worked as a maitre
d at both New York locations I've never
been to either I've only been to Nobu in
Vegas Nobu restaurants are designed for
VIPs I recognize 20 undisguised names on
the reservations roster including
oscar-winning actors Emmy winning
showrunner Marvel Comics actress several
famous for being famous socialites etc
etc half of them come with their own
security you can expect at least one
table a night clandestinely filled with
bodyguards acting like guests that's
funny when I was in I go to Las Vegas
twice a year and summed for a con for
and sometimes we stay at the Wynn and
multiple times I've run into Steve Wynn
and his security detail one night we
were at a restaurant at the Wynn I
forget the name of it but in come Steve
Wynn and at the next table over two
security guys sit down and it's just
Steve Wynn with a few young much younger
women at a table and then his security
having their own meal at the next table
over and then later on that same week we
were near like the I think it was like
near the high roller craps table or
something and one of the people I was
with pulls me out of the way and I
didn't even notice but Steve Wynn was
just marching on through with his
security who apparently were just gonna
move me if it became necessary yeah so
I'm familiar with the security
clandestinely or sometimes not so
clandestinely at the next table over De
Niro prefers the Sakae table you know
I'm finding this kind of a dumb article
this was not exactly what I expected
takeaway orders are delivered by private
jet Nobu doesn't offer takeaway the
restaurant smoked most common version
arrives via personal plane will do
twenty orders a month and more celebs
have a restaurant manager on speed dial
and it seems pretty clear that stuff is
just put on a plane and that's it staff
steers orders away from dishes involving
rice because that with raw fish is
fragile but caviar requests are honored
yeah this is just like a lead is
important I don't think we really need
to look at this anyway here's this I
don't need to actually read articles on
stream but this is just some of the
stuff I have bookmarked to read coffee
I'm interested in the humble brilliance
of Italy's mocha coffee pot I'm
interested in checking out mosquitos I
hate so I bookmark mosquito related
stuff it's time to get rid of the
lottery lottery stuff is interesting
alright so anyway I have always you know
I always have like 50 or so articles
here oh look and that's interesting
another air-conditioning related article
stop saying you're busy let's look at
that briefly I do find that annoying
when people say they're busy if you're
like a lot of people your response to
the question how you're doing is some
form of faux exasperated busy in West
culture how are you doing is basically a
greeting it's a form of hello but more
and more people do the humble brag of
saying that they're busy you might think
it's the truest response to a question
about status but it likely harms you
much more than you think a response of
busy and its accompanying tired sounding
vocal tone really communicates you've
lost control of your ability to
prioritize you're telling people you've
not figured out how to work with the
time you're given and we all have the
same amount of time yeah yeah I've
talked about this before there's been a
sort of fetishization of being busy as a
kind of badge of your doing stuff right
and you are accomplishing things and so
on and so forth and I don't I don't
really like it I mean sometimes I will
tell people I've been extremely busy if
I've been extremely busy for example the
last couple of weeks but busyness as a
badge of honor and the fetishization of
work I don't think it's great ok so
there there are some pocket articles let
me say thanks to a few other people and
then answer questions from the chat
photon has subscribed with twitch Prime
and I very much appreciate that I want
to say thanks to Emma Baker who has
signed up on my website as a new member
that is new member number 3 of 12 on my
website we are 25% of the way to me
opening the phone lines the voicemails
just continue to stream in fever n't up
that one on urban dictionary
I just set for date four eight four I
just signed up as a member and I'm
getting thank you for your support but
I'm also getting and I am not authorized
I I don't I don't know I didn't see your
membership come in so it's not clear
that the membership has gone through yet
unless you signed up with one of the
names that I just mentioned let me take
a listen let's let's just take a peek a
little peek behind the curtain here's
another voicemail that came in the phone
lines are not open yet but I will
potentially open them in a bit hello
this is Jim skulls my numbers 9 1 0 and
I will have to stop it there because I
don't want to Doc's anybody so that
one's no good I'm not going to put
numbers right out on air ok and that's
it so it seems like the phone numbers
are so
of calming down there yeah okay let me
say thank you to oh no I thought there
was another new twitch prime subscriber
yeah hey this is weird
I got an email yesterday after the
stream from someone saying hey David I
tried to subscribe with twitch prime but
it wouldn't let me I don't know what
that means I just I just don't
understand what you mean if if you can
be more specific I might be able to help
out there should be something if you put
your mouse over the main screen that
will say free sub ready if you're Amazon
Prime twitch Prime subscription has
expired
or you've not used it yet but beyond
that I don't know I mean it's it seems
to be working fine all sorts of people
are signing up so I don't I don't know
what to tell you Darth Bane gifting 5
tier 1 subs to Samsa BAM Rube Goldberg
machine falciform marquee fee and Bailey
Bell thank you very much I appreciate
that Oh people asking about the Sam
Harris interview yeah so I interviewed
Sam Harris today we were scheduled to
speak for like 50 to 60 minutes and we
ended up speaking for really close to 90
minutes where is my list actually have a
list of interesting things that we
discussed I think the plan is going to
be where did my list go so I think the
plan with the Sam Harris interview is
going to be so first of all my idea of
50 minutes was that it could be an
entire broadcast show our broadcast show
is like 52 minutes without commercials
so my plan was to use it as an entire
episode it's now nearly 90 minutes so we
can't do that so at least on YouTube we
are going to publish the interview next
week but some of the things that were
discussed sam discussed similarities and
differences between Osama bin Laden and
Trump which I think people will find
interesting he talked about his thoughts
about Trump voters he talked about
Donald Trump and racism
he had interesting thoughts about Fox
News he talked about the culture and
religion of gun
in the United States he talked about
immigration policy among the 2020
Democratic candidates he talked about
reparations we talked about terrorist
manifestos and what I asserted was a
double standard that he has applied to
terrorist manifestos so there's a lot of
interesting stuff a lot of interesting
stuff that we talked about and I think
it will be really interesting so my plan
is we're going to clip some of the six
or seven things I just mentioned we're
going to clip and publish individually
over the weekend probably and then early
next week Monday Tuesday we're gonna
publish the entire 90-minute interview
so it is pretty good okay people are
asking me about these twitch channel
points I don't really know much about it
I got an email from twitch about it and
I don't fully get I guess people can
earn points towards stuff but I think I
have to set it up in some way shape or
form I don't really know I mean I I've
not looked into it and I was actually
going to ask people today whether this
is something that we should be paying
more attention to it's like there's bits
there's points there's twitch Prime subs
there's tier 1 tier 2 tier 3 it's an
engagement the more you spend time on
the stream oh okay
interesting I have 540 points huh I
don't even know where people I don't
even know where people are seeing that
to be honest I'd be interested in
learning more about it it gives you a
point now and then up to 1200 points
mm-hmm
I don't know atheist Ireland no bottom
right of the chat channel points oh yeah
watch David Pakman earned Channel points
unlock rewards points may reset on
October 15th that's funny
have I seen ask yourself Svidler what
that is you can redeem points for prizes
make sure to shill for September this
month I don't even know what September
is I think it's twitch Prime subs or
half-price or is it all subs or
half-price can someone tell me
all subs are half-price even listen even
more of a reason to sign up please sign
up if you have Amazon Prime subscribe
with twitch prime I guess that one
doesn't matter because it's free to you
anyway
and otherwise right that's it I'm so
stupid twitch Prime subs are free
they're always free regular subs are
half-price very very good I appreciate
it
okay very good alright I guess we don't
need to talk more twitch prime is also
half off yeah I get it people are
trolling me no no big deal
alright I had okay so does anyone want
to play me--only chess I see people
saying it and I need some way if I just
open it to everyone I think I'll get too
many challenges I'm David Pakman on li
chess but I think what we should do in
the sort of interests of maybe trying to
open phone lines is if you want to play
me on LI chess sign up for a membership
and then post in the chat at message me
in the chat that you signed up and then
we can play Li chess if you want Ford 84
84 is asking if their membership went
through there is no membership I mean
you have to tell me what name you signed
up under the people that I've announced
are Siobhan Cavanaugh Nick Swenson and
Emma Baker those are the only people
whose payments have actually gone
through what may have happened
Ford is you created an account but the
payment didn't go through which is why
you're logged in to my website you
created an account but the payment
didn't go through it would be your email
Jay Ford you're saying no I'm not seeing
any any memberships with that email so I
think that that's what happened you your
payment itself must have failed oh I
wonder if I can even find a failed
payment here anyway it's too much to
look through off off the bat but no you
you have not successfully signed up yeah
apologies for that sorry
okay let's check in on the CNN Town
Hall's the climate change town halls and
see what's happening
[Music]
oh the amy klobuchar i want to start in
which of course is extremely the top
democratic presidential campus listen
through tonight on the heels of the
deadly hurricane durian which is leaving
neighborhoods under water in the bahamas
utter devastation it now heads north
along the united states coast for the
latest on durian let's go now to the CNN
Weather Center to our meteorologist
Jennifer gray Jennifer hi Erin that's
right this storm actually strengthened
just a little bit in the five o'clock
advisory now just shot we're not really
doing weather stuff on the David Pakman
show okay i people are asking what my
chess rating is again depending on the
time control it's between like 1100 and
1300 I think in really fast stuff which
I rarely play it's really low I think
like 30 second chess I've only played
one game against destiny and I lost so
I'm sure my rating is very very low okay
let me move over to what did I want to
go to next oh okay
I wanted to check out what stories we
have that might be good fits for
tomorrow I don't know that I want to
cover this story dan Crenshaw's worried
that universal background checks might
keep him from arming his friends it's
unclear why he doesn't think his friends
could pass a background check I saw that
earlier and I just I'm so sick of Dan
Crenshaw I don't even know that I want
to cover that hundreds of other people
could be implicated in the Jeffrey
Epstein and gee I don't know how this
pronounce name is pronounced Ghislaine
just Lane maxwell court documents uh
i've been covering Jeffrey Epstein but I
don't know if I want to keep talking
about it how do you politely end a
conversation with a person who won't
stop talking I actually have a way that
I do it worst case I've ever had I
basically gave every verbal cue I know
of eventually stood up then stood in the
doorway then backed out of the doorway
and this dude was still talking in the
end I just said I'll be back and closed
the door in his mid-sentence so I what I
this doesn't really work at personal
events but what at any kind of business
related event what I found is a useful
way to end the conversation as you say
do you have a business card and that
will usually interrupt and it feigns
interest because you want the person's
business card and then in the brief
pause that's created when they hand you
the business card you then say it's
really great to meet you I'll follow up
with you soon I've got to go catch up
with someone and it creates a pretty
good break and then you can interrupt in
personal conversations when it's not
like a business type of event it can be
tougher to end a conversation with
someone who is like this completely
determined completely determine not to
end the conversation with you let's see
what other ideas people are presenting I
don't mean to interrupt but sometimes
you just do that yeah I mean sometimes
you can do that and you just have to
interrupt and apologize for interrupting
and then you walk away that's a
possibility I'm looking at like top
level comments we have a great line we
use in Ireland the person is rabbiting
on and is showing no incite no signs of
stopping you clearly and firmly say I'll
let you go then you turn around and
stride away yeah that's that's one that
I sometimes use but it doesn't really
work where you say listen that yeah now
I know exactly what you mean I don't
want to take up too much of your time
but it's been really great meeting you
and I'll catch up with you know
something like that that's that's not a
bad option
Mosca Mitch doesn't like being called
moscow' Mitch I've covered that before
probably nothing I'm going to talk about
tomorrow what else do we have
Trump's tariffs expected to hit women
and lower-income Americans the hardest
Jeanine Pirro confirmed she was
suspended by Fox News for Islamophobic
comments this is an interesting story to
me because there's this thing that
happens on fox news often where people
will say something Oh God people will
say something that is like extremely
offensive and then you will see that
they all of a sudden are on vacation
from Fox News but it's never actually
said that they were suspended but we
kind of infer it and Jeanine Pirro is
saying that she was suspended by Fox
News for Islamophobic comments now what
I don't understand is I don't really
think Fox News cares about people saying
this stuff
like when Tucker Carlson says immigrants
make the country poorer and dirtier or
whatever something like that and then he
goes on vacation or laura ingraham
something similar happened when she went
after david hog one of the victims of
the florida parkland Florida shooting
Fox News should say that the person has
been suspended in order to appear to
care about people saying this stuff I I
don't know that I totally understand
the suspension that's not made public
doesn't really make sense to me oh do
people need to get banned do we not have
any moderators here today I thought we
had some moderators here hmm oh I see
one person who should be banned yep okay
it's free to ban people so that's that's
the great thing I can just keep doing it
if people want to be moderators you have
to contact me through my website contact
form with a link to your twitch account
it's too crazy to handle it during live
streams but if you want to be a
moderator then please do that let me say
thank you to oh boy a lot of people to
say thanks to call me crimes subscribed
with twitch prime seabone TV subscribed
with twitch prime French spit subscribed
with twitch prime Salta cracy subscribed
with twitch prime JT STJ subscribed with
twitch prime appreciate the two cheers
from cash chat actually I should see
whether there are any messages with that
sometimes people do send a message with
those cheers and I don't always see them
let's take a look here no there were no
messages okay very good side beard 92
has subscribed for one month at Tier one
thank you Amy AK has subscribed with
twitch Prime and gorilla wits has
subscribed with twitch Prime I also want
to say thanks to Jason Ford for signing
up as a new david pakman show member new
member number four of twelve of the
evening very good so a Ford I don't know
okay it worked with the membership yes
it did
and I don't know if you were one of the
people that wanted to challenge me
on LI chess with a membership if you
were let me know what now I'm now I'm
not sure whether Ford was one of the
people that wanted to play against me in
chess I'll just wait a moment to see
what they say it should be a sub
five-minute game if so I think otherwise
it's gonna go on too long people may get
bored and in the meantime we're a third
of the way to opening up the phone lines
I would love to open the phone lines
today am I gonna read Dave Reubens book
I'm not I don't read any of that like
pop politics stuff I just I have too
many other things to read and it's I
can't do it
Ford 84-84 says no you'd kick my ass Dee
Pakman better for other people okay Ford
84-84 if you want to deputize someone to
play against me in chess then that's
fine dick on man Woodie six wants me to
recommend some books I actually
recommended a few books earlier this
week on the show I'll tell you what they
are I don't even remember so I'll pull
up the list so I recommended for fiction
delta-v by Daniel Suarez and the Count
of Monte Cristo by Alexandre Dumas which
is of course an oldie but a goodie
delta-v is an awesome new sci-fi book
sort of a space mining it's very well
done and I read it in like five days on
vacation a couple weeks ago and then for
nonfiction I recently read plutocrats by
Christian Freeland about this sort of
new plutocratic over class that has
developed very very well-written and I
also read just an epic page turning
caper American kingpin the epic hunt for
the criminal mastermind behind the Silk
Road that's by Nick Bilton which is
really really good please don't
deputized deputize Daniel Rivera to play
against me in chess cuz he's way better
than me and he crushed me last time I
believe so I'd rather play against
someone who maybe I have a shot at
defeating would I go on Rubens show
gladly uh anytime but I don't think that
he's going to invite me anytime soon I'm
not gonna
all right so we've gotten that out of
the way all right
there are a few other things I wanted to
mention before I move on Oh someone's
leaving someone just left ten voice
mails in a row
probably increasingly furious about the
phone lines not being open okay Ford's
asking how to deputize someone to play
chess against me just do an at David
Pakman and say I'm deputizing X person
to play against you and then that person
can challenge me on Lee chess and I'll
play for them and he's Super Mario
Brothers today yeah I might I might play
a little more a little bit later did
Ruben explain the lies you've told about
him nope nope I've asked for people to
ask him for me because he won't talk to
me anymore about what were the lies that
he told that I told and I've not gotten
any kind of answer unfortunately I would
love to hear about what lies I told and
if so if I if I lied I would gladly
correct it that's no problem whatsoever
but I've been nobody's telling me what
lie what lie I told and I nobody tells
me I can't do much about that I should
get into newer games yeah yeah I just I
just don't have that much time for video
gaming that's the truth
crun subscribed with twitch prime I
appreciate it and cash chat sending
another hundred bit cheer which I very
much appreciate thank you very much
Ruben joined the blaze yep I saw that
okay all right I guess Ford I guess
you're not deputizing anyone to play
against me in in chess which is totally
fine yeah a lot of trolls in the chat
right now that's true disappointing in
some sense what do I think of Calcasieu
I met him in person at pathetic con last
year perfectly respectful young guy
whose politics I completely disagree
with and find deplorable in just about
every way but he was extraordinarily
respectful to me he clearly knew who I
was came up to me and
hi and we talked for five minutes while
in the background Hassan [ __ ] was
yelling at Charlie Kirk and Charlie Kirk
was yelling at Jen Gujarat I know if
people remember that okay all right
let's go back to possible stories for
tomorrow so the Jeanine Pirro story I'm
potentially covering tomorrow what else
do we have here
shadowy think-tank pushing to kick 3.1
million people off of food stamps not
hugely surprising owner of Fah King good
says he's not in on the joke that's
funny all right let's see what else
we've got a town for people with chronic
fatigue syndrome that's interesting only
a third of Americans believe Jeffrey
Epstein commits suicide yeah I've
continued to hear more and more about
that pros and cons of rent control that
might be a topic for a future episode
not that much obvious news that's great
for the show sometimes you've got to dig
a little deeper and get into some more
niche stories a lot of the headlines
these days are not actually looking that
good for my show anyway
NRI called Walmart's and you stand some
guns shameful actually this I do want to
talk about Walmart not to say Walmart
doing anything amazing but Walmart is
doing more than the president to curb
gun violence which is shocking or are
people wanting who I don't I'm trying to
understand somebody wants who is it that
wants to play chess against me tit
'can't offed or French spit I don't it
seems like someone someone seemed to say
they wanted to play chess against me
I've not gotten any challenge how about
this if you want to take Ford's chess
match against me which he earned by
becoming a member on my website
challenge me now I'm David Pakman on li
chess and then Ford can just type in the
chat who it is that he wants to transfer
his game to or something like that that
might be better
oh now Ford is saying that they do want
to play
Oh French spit was deputized how my
goodness this is getting a little bit
too complicated
French spit okay all right French spit
just send me a challenge I'm sure I'll
get crushed I mean I'm terrible but it's
fun Ethan Haas key was that is that
French spit it just disappeared it
popped up and disappeared
Ida tell me explain to me your username
on li Ches anybody Ethan Haas is a hask
okay so who is French spit I'm David
Pakman only Ches waiting for the
challenge from French spit weird
now nothing's happening oh man I I
thought this was gonna be a quick and
easy sort of thing but hmm French spit
going once
signing on oh okay
I got your friend spit very good thank
you Jacob Walt wanted on felony warrant
yeah I saw that it's not really a story
for my show I mean the guy's like not
even the guy says just so lame but I did
notice that and it's kind of depressing
how do you find people on lead chefs I
have no idea I've never sent a challenge
so I don't really know I have I had a
crazy encounter with a fan no comment no
man did in my perspective on Sam's did
my conversation with Sam Harris changed
my perspective of him no I already had a
pretty good sense of him I had a pretty
good sense of him do I listen to Kim
Iverson no I don't debate Sam cedar I
don't believe is French spit unless that
is French spit can somebody tell me who
French spit is on li Ches hmm
all right well maybe I'll just accept
this challenge in the mean time and then
we'll get to French spit this is not
even a timed game crazy enough I'll just
play my sort of normal opening against
white in this scenario in this case I
don't usually take French spit okay yeah
I'll get I will I will go right after
this game I can't imagine this game will
take very long okay provisional rating
on this user could be very good could be
not very good I don't have any idea all
right
I've played chess with destiny for
people asking about that no actually
let's go right after the Queen briefly
and make him make a move it doesn't see
this could be good for me saw it okay
could trade queens or not trying to
think here and then here is that useful
not really if I take the Queen and then
here and then here actually that sort of
works and then now this is an issue yep
didn't see it
okay so like there's a free pond this
night seems like it might eventually get
trapped could also actually I think this
is looking good here just to get that
aligned not sending is seeing any
obvious reason not to go here unless
it's defended I mean I guess I'll take
it right okay I mean I guess I'll take
it again and then let's see so if I move
this we have revealed' check or do I go
after the rook first I mean I guess I'll
come over here and take a pawn
it's another free pun here and here I
mean depending on can't defend both I
don't think okay guess I'll take here
should really get this out of the way
and then okay
I mean threatening here can't really do
much free rook yeah so I'll just take
yeah okay all right let's go now - I'm
still not seeing the challenge from
French spit I seat it can't off but not
French spit French spit is there
infinite void I am still not seeing
French spit now we're not doing a
rematch right now French spit what is
your username I seat it can talk and
infinite void French spit seems to be
gone I don't I don't really get it
French spit
anybody know Yes No maybe so
I I don't know I thought that we were
all set up for a game but I guess not
all right I'm gonna have to move on I
think okay people want one more game or
are we moving on from this I could play
tit contort infinite void I would
probably ticket off because a
five-minute game an infinite void wants
to play ten plus ten which is not what
I'm looking to do right now it won't let
you sign in okay all right I'll plate it
can't oft and then we'll call it a night
for chess and I'm black again here okay
ooh okay huh I think that was actually a
mistake yet there's a there's a line
here actually that is devastating
devastating for white which I could show
later and he got out of it
I guess what do I want to do here trying
to remember the right so this is a
reveal check so that would not work here
here here should get out of the way of
then of the bishop so I'll go here just
try going after the Queen and see if he
sees that all right all right well that
was a mistake did not see that let me go
back there's a very interesting line
that has I've won a guy won games like
this endless times okay starts like this
the point here is usually this square
right because you've got both of these
pieces on this square and I think I've
won probably 20 games I play here hold
on a second oh right analysis board
I will play here and then they usually
will take and then this is where they
get confused because I will actually
move here and very often white if they
don't know the line they just try to
think of the most direct way to link up
sorry to link up these two pieces again
and so what they'll play is right here I
will take with the Queen and players
will often still be unsure about this
line and they will just see this as very
appealing and they see this square as
attacking both the rook and the Queen so
they'll play here obviously the King
can't take four because that's check
so you're basically giving away this
rook you just play over here and this is
where if white doesn't know it they'll
come over here and then it's basically
over so I go here I'm attacking the rook
if the rook doesn't move I take it if
the rook moves here I take it so the
rook basically has no chance but to move
here now this is where the engine as you
can see will recommend going here but
it's not really the best move what I
will play is back down here for check
and then the there's two options there's
Queen here and then they give away the
Queen the other option that they will
play is they'll move the bishop back
which you immediately lose because it's
a smothered mate the bishop can't get
out of the way because there's this
check I've probably won 20 or 25 games
like this
yeah and clearly a lot of people a lot
of people know that okay alright let me
say thanks to we have another new member
here a John Livingston John Livingston
is new member number five of 12 of the
evening you know I hate to break this to
you everybody I think we're gonna fail
to get the new member to achieve new
member targets once again today
yesterday the target was 15 and we got
to five
today the target was 12 and we got to
five and we may not get there let me say
thanks to some people mira vez pants
subscribed for two months with twitch
prime who's ready for another year of
campaign yes indeed Beastmaster felix
has subscribed with twitch prime lychee
Popo has subscribed at Tier one
tied well welcome subscribed for two
months at Tier one sole control and 99
subscribed with prime and white oh for
subscribing with twitch prime I should
go back to ten members man okay let's
let's make a deal
I will effective immediately move the
goal from 12 to 10 members if 5 people
in the chat will say that they will get
memberships otherwise if either way
we're not going to get 5 I don't know
what the point is but if people if 5
people were interested in memberships I
would drop it to 10 is the goal and then
we would immediately get the phone lines
open which will allow me to take a whole
bunch of phone calls since it's still
early in the evening do we have 5 people
who are willing to sign up for a
membership if we reduce the goal to 10
tell Parian says they would do it but
they're lying so I guess we could count
that potentially what about 5 actual
people okay cell Tok recei is number 1
French spit says they'll get a second
membership okay I guess that's number 2
with the coupon code half 19 memberships
are only 3 bucks a month
bride clutches number 3 Bobby butts is
going to ask their mom about it sonic
Pegasus I guess is saying number 4 I'm
not really sure about that legalize
ranch is number 4 / 3 4 3 4 / 5 it's
unclear who is actually saying that they
would do it that's weird someone is
already a member okay well very good I
appreciate that please don't cancel and
re-subscribe no that doesn't make any
sense
French spit is going to get multiple
memberships I don't know this is not
making sense
hmmm yeah it's extremely confusing
what's going on honestly I'm not sure
anybody's getting any memberships all
right we'll listen let's just try it
we're gonna switch we the goal is now
officially 10 we've dropped it from 15
to 12 to 10 and their absolute
we are people trolling but you know what
that's okay it's really not a big deal
people want a troll that comes with the
territory but in the meantime if you
were one of those people who was gonna
sign up if we lowered the goal to tend
to open the phone lines please do it now
and I've got even more voicemails coming
in and I'm gonna play a couple of them
for you just to take a listen to the
type of thing that is happening all the
time oh actually hold on let me pull up
I lost my voicemails let's take a listen
here
hmm okay there's something actually
really weird going on let me take a
listen it's silence silent voicemail
that's weird
all right let's take a listen to another
one he David and I just okay that's not
really going anywhere and we got one
more
David David this is Dave California and
I saw your piece on um how about
president there's no history it was
congratulating Poland yeah on an
anniversary of the invasion in their
country by Nazi Germany but you are on
the mark though the reason that people
are gonna think this is enough isn't it
gets him congratulating him is because
they don't know history so that's why he
can get away with it Ian graduate him
and people will think it's good but a
majority that people don't really know
history all they know is yes all very
very good points well made and well
taken but I would probably if we were
having a conversation have been able to
move that or wrong move that along a
little bit more quickly okay let me say
thank you to Joshua Meyers Joshua Meyers
has signed up for a membership in his
number six of ten the target is 10 this
is only four more we could have the
phone lines opened in mere seconds okay
number seven
Brian McGovern Brian McGovern is new
member number seven of the evening that
gets us down to only three more now
we've now we're building a little bit of
momentum here I actually like what's
going on here three more website members
and we will get those phone lines opened
right up we have now Alec Hummer Alec
Hummer is new member number eight of ten
this is exciting we might actually get
the phone lines open it's so depressing
when we fail after streams I just hang
my head in shame
we're not not able to get a new member
target so maybe we'll be able to do it
today people asking by the way why we
prefer website memberships over
everything else
we keep 97.1% of every website
membership payment we keep much less
than that I know I'm not supposed to say
but we keep much less than that when
people support us on every single other
platform it is not 97.1% let me say
thank you to origins and tall tales for
cheering one bit and then one bit again
and then one bit again let me see if
there are any messages alongside those
cheers should probably make the minimum
cheer like 50 bits right I'm at 780
points I want to cheer not troll okay
very good I appreciate that
she's a she's a lion dog cheered 200
bits and the King clawed subscribed for
one month at tier one which I very much
appreciate all right we are to website
members away from opening up the phone
lines let me see here alright I will
play one more game against debate Sam
cedar while we wait for possibly two
more new memberships and then we will
look at opening the phone lines let's
hope we make it happen I've been black
three games in a row now on lis chess
which is odd sell you a membership
listen memberships are our primary
source of funding we create extra
content for our members and it is the
most direct way to just support the
program's you like there's no middle man
or middle person of any kind alright it
looks like the bait Sam cedar went away
I don't know that they know that I
accepted their challenge yeah they must
have gone away it's too bad
well if they come back they're in the
game with me they would be able to play
against me
did I talk to Sam Harris about direct
support versus advertising no our um the
half-off code is half nineteen our
conversation was really political in
nature so we didn't we didn't talk about
any of that okay Ethan HASC is
challenging me all right
I'm gonna play Ethan if by the end of
this game we've not gotten to the ten
new members I think we're gonna bail on
it for the evening let's see what we can
do here against Ethan alright let's
let's see if he falls for the line again
no he's not falling for it okay I
usually play here and then take on this
pin this position now doesn't really end
up benefiting me that much but next I
usually start moving pawns although
maybe it makes sense to get a rook now I
guess I'll go with this mmm still go
here
so now we can go here and then if takes
with either one we've still got a couple
more pieces there or I could back off
I'll try it right all right well we're
back we've gone one do I play here here
here it's an opportunity to get the rook
in I might want to open this up a little
bit this is where I struggle where I
don't know sort of how to build an
attack in anyway so here but there's a
lot of pressure on this square I have
one extra piece let's try it right well
that's the way to short-circuit that I
think I'm gonna leave the tension there
and maybe I might go after this piece
and see if the Queen eventually moves
right well that was an obvious mistake
maybe I'll try doubling up over here
maybe try to maneuver this Knight over
hmm so there is a free pawn here if
they're a risk to taking it then would
have to defend this one I think I'm
gonna try it I don't see it's not
obviously wrong to me so we'll see
will white defend this pawn or choose
some counter-attack of course just
moving this would attack the Queen
there's a lot of options here which
would force me immediately to have to
retreat get a look behind the pond so
here you mean okay so we can trade
Queens
maybe I'll just be greedy and take the
pawn and see where we go from there now
this is undefended now it's defended
let's see so if I take take and then
take I'm getting another pawn advantage
which is not it's not terrible given the
circumstances mmm let's try it right
missed that
so I'm still just up the two so it's not
that much of a win um could I somehow
get here actually I'll go this way
yeah this is hanging but as of right now
that's undefended but I guess here now
this is definitely undefended
maybe I'd push the pond yeah I'm so
stupid
what am i doing I completely missed that
this was just hanging yeah all right now
do I move this out of the way I guess
now I can play let's let's see
interesting this can't be taken can I
then maneuver the night somewhere
interesting not sure but this could
potentially be interesting now I'm going
to try this
right so now that that is a problem I
guess I go back here and defend
hmm actually got a game here now I can
give this away rather we could trade
here but then this would no longer be
defended so that's interesting here if I
go here yeah I think this is the move
actually it didn't quite work if I go
here here attacks here attacks but can I
get this out of the way
maybe I just put the second rook on it
right that was not that was not the way
to go not a good move
it's all falling apart yep terrible
terrible terrible I completely have lost
here okay I guess I'm just gonna start
trying to push up here yeah we're
screwed
completely screwed all right I'm gonna
resign I had Bishop takes F to let me
look at that F to here I did not have
Bishop takes F - at what point did I
have Bishop takes F - oh here I had
bishop takes F - yeah that's interesting
let me analyze that oh but no I actually
played the recommended move though the
engine did not recommend Bishop takes F
- I'm guessing you meant at this point
yeah go back to the tower moves yes I
believe Oh here I had bishop takes F -
wow I really messed that up
Wow yep Bishop takes that then has to
move here then I just win the rook yeah
Wow that was devastating this is why I'm
not good at chess this is why I do
politics okay all right that's it I lost
that was a problem okay we've got a
bunch of new members coming in Brad Mia
is new member number 9 French spit is
new member number 10 Scott Jackson is
new member number 11 Maxime Kozak is new
member number 12 a French spit is with
another membership number 13 Devon
Guthrie is number 14 Wow 14 we could
have kept it at 12 all along okay
thank you so much for the support keep
them coming let's get the phone lines
open let's do it we've been waiting long
enough my friends Wow I mess this game
up so royally yeah Wow Wow
chess is easier to watch them play yeah
that is definitely true all right let me
get set up for phone calls here the
number is six one seven eight three zero
47:56 one seven eight three zero 4750
will put up
the YouTube and twitch subscriber slash
followers and see if we can get these
pumped up while we are talking oh and
before I do that I've got to get myself
connected to the phone system give me
just one second
the number is 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 of
course I will be taking phone calls
momentarily let's get set up here
[Music]
hmm no greeting I'm on my own phone line
there's supposed to be a greeting that's
weird when we try calling back there are
people holding so clearly it's working
hmm it's just strange why am I not
hearing my own greeting are other people
not getting them reading the greeting
when they call in oh yeah it looks like
I am on but there's there was no
greeting that's very strange okay oh you
got the greeting all right I'll have to
look into that all right in the meantime
YouTube versus twitch follower
subscriber challenge alright let's see
what we can do with that happening live
let's go to our first caller from the
202 area code caller from 202 what's
your name where are you calling from
caller from 202 can you hear me do you
have us maybe muted hmm
no - OH - alright let's try our caller
from the eight one six area code who's
calling today from eight one six oh no
is something wrong with the phone system
[Music]
are people hearing me via the phone that
would be question number one unlikely
that with two people we're having the
same issue the number is six one you can
hear me oh well I know you can oh you're
eight one six yeah you're on right now
hey French spit do you are you are you
muted did you mute yourself because
you're just not coming through I don't
know what's going on
hmm that's weird
let's try pulling in someone from the
three one nine area code hey three one
nine are you able to hear me hmm
something definitely seems to be going
on and I'm not totally sure what it is
eight one six you're still on can you
hear me now hmm all right let's take a
look at a couple of other things let's
see eight one six can you hear me now I
can hear you
brilliant okay now we can hear you as
well yep there was a setting wrong on my
apologies
oh no yeah it's fine fine okay so what
by the way obviously I do the whole
great fan of the show big fan of the
show thing thank you get me an arguments
with my with people who don't follow
politics all the time right okay so I'm
kinda on that subject my sister is this
like she's a lot like me in many ways
and the interesting thing is that she
seems to be on the right but other than
that we're pretty similar on our
interest comedy and stuff in music and
things like that but she's very you know
right-wing it seems now watching a lot
of steven crowder and things and I was
just gonna wonder I was wondering if you
think that political views have any
weight or if personalities really have
any impact on your political views if
those things are you know related really
or if it's just kind of a algorithm you
know I have no idea what you mean are
you saying is there a correlation
between certain personality types and
certain political orientations yeah I'm
afraid that I just stumbled upon your
channel
arbitrarily and that's why I'm left-wing
when because my sister shares so many of
my personality traits and she I think
happens to be right-wing I just didn't
know if you maybe shared that sentiment
well I think that there's definitely a
predisposition to certain political
ideas but a lot of it has to do with
family upbringing and there's also some
studies on like the brains of
conservatives versus the brilliant
brains of liberals it's interesting when
you have a family member
particularly someone who shares a lot of
the same DNA that has drastically
different little views because it makes
us wonder well like how did that develop
what is the combination of factors that
caused that driving right so I mean I
think all of these things are related
there are you know we've learned that
conservatives have large larger fear
centers in their brain for example like
that is a very specific and and real
difference but it also seems as though
family and environment is a big part of
it so I think it's a it's a nature
combined with nurture thing right right
that is very interesting and I and I
hope that the further educated you know
we as people get the more concrete our
views are so great insight thank you all
right thanks for the call appreciate it
let me say thanks to Robert Spears who
is today's 15th look I could have kept
the goal at 15 after all 15 new website
members this evening also want to say
thanks to Miss face 6 who subscribed for
a month at tier 1 and thanks to
anonymous cheerer for cheering to bits
to bits thank you very much we're taking
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go next
to our caller from the 405 area code
who's calling today from 405 hello yes
yeah so I think that's me all right
that's you okay thank you so I am
calling to talk a little bit about
mental health just yeah big simon 'show
thank you for what you do and what your
internal is but yeah get into it go and
talk a little bit about mental health
and ask you
so so they've been bringing it up a lot
again you know with the whole you know
what's been going on with the tragedies
with the gun tragedies and I want to
know what your thoughts are on I mean so
they're calling for mental health checks
which I'm not saying I agree or disagree
with but the problem is which mental
health problems are what we going to to
prevent
for example I mean so when I think about
somebody maybe that has PA PTSD from
being abused right and you know a like a
somebody that's coming from a like a
household where there was you know pukes
I mean are we preventing them because we
also know that a lot of like people you
know a lot of Y like ex-wives and that
spouses end up being murdered by their
spouse so I mean I think I think we're
into some tricky line there so oh and I
want you to kind of know what your take
is on that
yeah I've talked about this before with
mental health professionals so there's
two issues with the people that say what
we need to focus is not guns but the
mental health elements number one a lot
of those same people don't want to
properly fund D stigmatize and provide
access to mental health services it's a
stunning hypocrisy and double standard
and that at its face takes so much
credibility away from a lot of these
people that want to talk about mental
health that's first and foremost once
you get beyond that you're bringing up a
very good point which is what is the
list of conditions which would preclude
you from having a firearm and this is
extraordinarily complicated if someone
has generalized anxiety disorder that is
someone with a diagnosed mental health
condition who has been evaluated by a
mental health professional does that
mean you cannot have a firearm I'm
asking the question I don't know the
answer so yeah this is a major problem
and this is why when we flippantly here
the more guns and more places you know
fetishist say don't look at guns you've
got to just look at you've got to look
at mental health I mean you've got to
look at gun safes and education and
whatever they are not there they're
saying it without even understanding
what they're talking about yeah and I
know so I just want to speak a little
bit
the what I feels like if stigmatization
that also happens when you're
associating people all sorts of inherent
problems with violent behave yeah
without saying that most people who have
a diagnosed what we would call a mental
health diagnosis are not violent people
who are not going to become violent
people period okay well that's that's
kind of what I want to do here thoughts
on but yeah thank you thank you for you
know I like that I like the I like your
take on it and I agree thank you thank
you so much appreciate the phone call
this is interesting at the same time
we're getting like a little pop of
subscribers on both twitch and YouTube
YouTube interestingly seems to be off
the edge of the screen and that's too
bad let me see if I can fix that
there we go oh I see why I didn't do
that because it's causing a problem with
uh yeah interesting so I can't really do
that let me see if I can just scroll
over no I can't let me see if I can zoom
out there we go
yeah I don't know what's going on but
we're getting like a pop-up subscribers
on both twitch and YouTube at the same
time I'm wondering if like did Sam
Harris tweet that he was on my show or
something like that or what what would
cause subscriber and follower numbers to
pop at the same time like that that's
interesting okay all right well guess
we'll never know in any case let's go
back to let's go to the 662 area code
who's calling today from six six two
hello yes that's you good who's this
Josh focusing hey Josh what's going on
oh man question bro whatever is regards
to unity on the Left I've been a
left-wing daddy for like almost forever
oppressive Bernie I guess a present
right right wing you know not really
fundamentalist
you know they weren't on the lot of
things about you know abortion and thing
like that but they were very loving on a
lot of other issues but yeah my question
is you think at the left will benefit
more from from unity from each other
like of course when it comes to the
mainstream like you know dnt be like
that
a lot of stuff is split because of money
you know influence from other people all
this other kind of thing but as far as
like shows like yours shows like destiny
shows like you know Sam cedar you know
when I see these guys you know basically
beefing with each other
binocular it really seems like it hurts
the left it seems like a divide that
doesn't need to be because you know
these guys can talk to each other more
freely than other politicians can so
I've talked about this before I think
that it's fine to have people under one
umbrella that don't agree with the chat
with each other on every issue and
that's it would be weird to think that
everybody would agree on every single
issue I think the problem becomes when
you start getting these sort of like
purity tests and litmus tests and
sometimes it the narcissism of small
differences takes over and that's where
the divisions become self-destructive in
many ways and so I've talked about this
and the other thing to understand is the
left is not more divided than the right
I know that the people like to say
there's people on the Left who like to
say this and people on the right who
likes to say who like to say this
there's a number of recent polls
including Gallup that show that the left
when it comes down to voting is not
actually a more divided than than the
right even though it might be a
narrative that's a popular one for
corporate media I see people in the chat
talking about the Bernie or bust
movement yeah that's a relatively small
part of of the left so yeah I agree with
you about the problem you're pointing
out I don't think it's that big of a
problem okay all right all right
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much people they're saying that the
reason I'm getting all these subscribers
is because of chess nerds chess nerds do
can somebody tell me what that means
that chess or Oh Destin E is hosting me
right now didn't get a notification
about that that's true I definitely did
not get a notification about that
[Music]
chess nerds is a chess community okay
awesome thanks to them let's see pet
FLA's subscribed for one month
Gyllenhaal's subscribed for one month
cray dia subscribed with prime the blind
leading the blind subscribed at Tier one
and I already mentioned miss Fei six I
appreciate that
let's see let's let's try again with the
202 area code that I couldn't hear
before - OH - what's going on who's this
okay see now I do think it's 202's fault
because before it was my fault but I
still can't hear - OH - oh yes what's
going on hey I wanted to get your
thoughts on a antifa
and the recent events AFC decided to
fund some and it gets bail money to get
him teeth out of jail I didn't hear
about that let's take a look at it AOC
and Tifa bail money not heard about that
okay so there's a fox news article is
there someone else who's reporting on it
I'm not seeing anybody else reporting on
that trying to look I'm just looking for
articles here okay AOC this is according
to Fox News a OC and I Anna Presley
vowed to contribute to a fund raising
bail money for the 36 counter protesters
irate arrested at the straight Pride
Parade I'm not seeing anything here that
says they were and Tifa people where
where are you seeing that
well that was generally the people that
were kind of protesting and you know you
can see from the videos I guess I don't
know it was covered widely in news
sources cuz the news event I'm having
trouble finding that information I mean
listen I'm against violence and I've
said that unconditionally I think that
the the you know I am against fascism as
an ideology but I am NOT in the in favor
of groups that use authoritarian or by
tactics to try to enforce their beliefs
and that's my view I mean I pay very
little attention to an Tifa because as
far as I know aunt Eve has never killed
anyone they're very very small a whole
bunch of things are called an Tifa that
actually aren't and I don't know I feel
like I've got more important things to
be looking at I don't know I think I'm
on the left like you I think we need to
call them out they're not making this
look good you know you made a video
about Amy now I know he's controversial
but you know you kind of raised some
points about why he you know maybe
shouldn't be trusted but does that
excuse the violence no I said in that
video it must have been 15 times that
the violence again okay all right I just
wanted to bring it up because I think I
think I want to live - I think we need
to be covering this I think we need to
be talking about it that being tactics
on okay right yet so who is saying that
these tactics that violence is okay well
it completes it it's implicit because
the banks like it well because the
mainstream media is generally not
covering as you said Fox News is the
only one covering that specific story
people aren't talking about it people
aren't explicitly saying that this is
not okay then that saying that every
that's like saying every random Muslim
if they don't condemn every single
instance of radical Islamic terror
they're implicitly endorsing it like
that's a crazy standard that doesn't
make any sense
I'm sure someone like that though
there's a pattern there where it's not
being covered it's not being it's
definitely not being condemned you know
Peter reporters were still reacting
asking people like you know see if they
will condemn and tithi and they want to
do it on camera so you're saying I think
you're saying you're you're saying
you're on the left and I respect that
what are your Morton what are your most
important like leftist positions that
you would subscribe the anti-war mostly
I'm against the prison industrial
complex I'm for or so
you know welfare programs I've got a
complex kind of political opinion but I
know left center left that's all being
recategorize at this point but all right
well here's my advice listen it sounds
like you and I agree that we should be
denouncing and condemning violence
I would suggest find the people who you
think aren't doing that and contact them
and tell them that they should do it
because I'm already doing it well yeah
so looking at a UC story and that was
why I came here see if you wanted to
cover that but thank you okay all right
thank you for the coffee beverage so
sorry I hit hang up and then I heard you
wanted to say another thing six one
seven eight three zero 4750 is the
number six one seven eight three zero
4750 is the number let's go next to
Grayson the deprogrammed
thirteen-year-old who we have heard from
before Grayson what's going on hey David
so um I'm officially not originally from
the San Francisco Bay Area and you know
they're having a house housing crisis
there of course those wondering do you
think the the fundamental like valack
supply and demand can release can really
apply the housing and like really tying
that to also like Andrew Yang's plan
there like ain't lettin blacks to relax
voting laws all across the country and
Elizabeth Warren's plan to to invest
lots in affordable housing because like
if if because I mean there are like the
Democratic socialists of America
LA when they created the terms Fendi
which is like public housing in my
backyard and opposing back not in my
backyard and then there's the yen bees
which are yes my backyard which really
kind of spread their legs to all of all
development projects so I feel like do
you think it can really apply to the
housing and housing prices can really
apply the supply and demand E because I
feel like there's also there's just such
a huge demand and they haven't been
building well Grayson let me ask you
this are you familiar with the economic
concept of elasticity of demand well
well I know price elasticity that cuz
reading about like inflation and ng
Ang's the universe basic
proposal how like not everything is
necessarily going to go up 10 percent
with the value-added taxes because not
every not because some things the price
can change though and there's people
will still buy it and not everything has
that elasticity absolutely so here's
basically the thing people there is an
inelastic demand for housing because
people need housing not having housing
is sort of like an emergency state that
we would call homelessness so you have
to account for that when you think about
supply and demand so housing is really a
segmented market if you want to look at
like luxury housing then you can make
the case which there's like a 300,000
surplus unit having California sorry I'd
have to say that sure yeah right so you
you have very different market dynamics
among like luxury housing for example
versus just any housing so I think once
you look at housing more generally or
specifically at housing that
lower-income people can afford it is not
subject to the rules of classical
economics and supply and demand and thus
it absolutely has to be dealt with
differently all right thank you all
right Grayson great to hear from you
Grayson the 13 year old let's go next to
our caller from the 6-5 one area code
who's calling today from six five one
hey david this is max you hear me yeah
what's going on max hey I was just
wondering what's your opinion on do you
think do you think the current lineup
for the Democrats is kind of set in
place or do you think we could maybe see
someone jump in late in the game or
what's your take on that
nope I think it's down to the final
three I think that you know Kamala
Harris is in fourth place and maybe if
something crazy happens at next week's
debate she might be in the running in
some way but I don't see any way at this
point for there to be you know most
everybody at this point is done and I
think if you go and look back at history
and you look at September of the year
before elections and primary polling I'm
not aware of it
ran in October sorry what was that I
think Bill Clinton announced in October
right so you could you'd have to go back
like what is that 28 years or something
like that
yeah so I think that it the most likely
thing is that the one of the top three
right now are ultimately going to be the
nominees okay cool thanks all right
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much okay on that note I want to thank a
few other people I want to thank
symbolic gamer who has subscribed with
Prime
I want to thank circa bong who has
subscribed at Tier one for one month I
want to thank San boxer who is here in
their second consecutive month of Prime
subscription sending the message palem
palem I wonder what that means does that
mean peace in some language let me sing
oh no it's Latin okay I don't know what
it means but I appreciate the sentiment
either way okay I'm not playing Super
Mario World today I've got a run I've
got to make dinner
but let's raid someone who should I be
raiding tell me who I should be raiding
this evening we raided we previously
raided trihex yesterday we raided Hasan
who should I raid today bad bunny is bad
bunny Oh bad bunny is chatting you know
what maybe as a goof we'll raid bad
bunny raid bad bunny let's do it this
could be a disastrous idea disastrous
idea but we're going to see off we go